what causes inflation inflation is the
rate at which prices increase across the
economy it helps explain why an American
big Maps cost less than three US Dollars
20 years ago but is around five dollars
today on the traditional explanation is
too much money chasing too few goods if
a central bank prints too much money or
makes
it slow then prices will rise
events like Wars would cause a shortage
of goods can also increase prices so a
little bit of inflation doesn't really
hurt anybody but when inflation is high
and volatile and when it's unexpected it
can do a lot of damage to the way a
capitalist system runs borrowing and
lending money becomes very difficult
businesses struggle to keep up with
Rising costs and they may be forced to
employ fewer people to avoid extremes of
inflation most central banks try and
keeping it around two percent to stop
prices from rising they can increase
interest rates but how exactly does that
work like the part two